hello I love homie Baker I'm on the
fragile states Council and at the moment
we are going to other councils to see
what kinds of ideas that we can share I
just came from the Council on terrorism
one of the ideas we discussed there was
the development of robotics there was
another person from another council who
was there and he was talking about the
ability me out of what I call weaponized
toys to be developed things like model
airplanes or helicopters to be fitted
with explosives and able to create great
destruction have their GPS systems etc
unmanned the kinds of vehicles that are
very independent self-sufficient of
course such robotic models can also be
used for a lot of good things as well
disaster relief demining rescue
operations etc so there's a an example
of a developing technology that can be
used either for good or for bad purposes
the problem in the discussion was what
we do about this how can it be regulated
how can any control so that the
destructive parts of it can entertain
and the feeling was that it can't be
controlled that the best way to deal
with an emerging technology like this is
to have more transparency more openness
and to stress the positive uses obsesses
such technology such that the
destructive uses would be d incentivized